Well, I get the first headline, they say, so here we go.
Starting with the latest vaccine news,
CBS news reports that Pfizer has completed a study
and found their vaccine is safe and 100% effective for kids,
this is big, ages 12 to 15.
So Pfizer plans to file with the FDA
for emergency use of the vaccine for kids as young as 12.
I know Drew, that there's still some vaccine hesitancy,
but that's changing.
I've heard people say, "I never got the flu shot."
The difference is,
if you didn't get the flu shot, it only affected you.
If you don't get this vaccine,
it affects all of us and the people around you,
so I think this is very exciting,
especially for kids because they can go back to school.
I don't know about Frankie and all,
but aren't they sick of just looking at a little zoom zoom?
Everyone has hit a fatigue level that is so real
and we know we're here for a little longer,
so the sooner we get vaccinated,
the better it will be out of it.
Have you? I've had mine.
I've had mine too.
So can we say we approve of the vaccine for children?
I do approve. Yes.
You approve.
I approve.
We approve.
Can I just you a funny thing Chris rock said to me
because people are saying, "Well, I don't know what's in it.
I don't know if it's safe."
And he said, "You don't know what's in Tylenol either
but when you have a headache, you take it.
Because you know it'll make your headache go away."
If it's something that makes you feel good,
makes you feel better and until we have information
to the contrary, I don't know,
I'm a big proponent of the vaccine.
I am too. And in all of this difficult roads
that we are all navigating,
I have come to have a new re-appreciation for entertainment.
Yeah. Me too.
I think when the world falls apart you just think,
"Entertainment, bigger picture problems."
And then you're at home for a long time
and you just need an escape.
An entertainment place.
Exactly. So a show like "Bridgerton"
the steaming Netflix hit
that broke records is coming back for season two.
It's been a personal favorite of mine.
Glamor reports that the show plans
to take some real life inspiration
from former Royals, Harry and Megan.
And in season two, the characters Simon and Daphne,
newlyweds, new parents will go
through some struggles similar to Megan and Harry.
I think being Royals, having public opinion,
being new parents are sort of the similar through lines.
Gail, I can't think of anyone we've looked
to for the North star other than you
and Oprah for all of the truths from Harry and Meghan.
I think that interview opened up conversations
that many people weren't prepared to have
or didn't wanna have.
But I think ultimately, it's about a family
that wants to be united and be together
and I'm hoping that that will be the case.
And have those difficult conversations...
Yes. Sometimes conversations are very difficult.
Right now I'm just happy for them,
I saw in the paper the other day that they said
that they're planning for a home birth,
I think that that's interesting.
I really admire hearing all the details
and opening up that important conversation
and really making history in a conversation
that was refusing to be heard for centuries.
So I'm very happy that the lid is off
and there's nothing healthy
about not having those tough conversations.
And there's nothing healthy when you don't talk.
So let's all wish that
for all involved in that particular story.
Okay. Gail your story up.
Okay, my turn again.
This is a good one.
A writer at cosmopolitan recently admitted
that she misses eavesdropping
on awkward first dates, I love this.
We all miss going out to restaurants.
Yeah, you do with your friends.
You also miss, ill bet, sitting your strangers
and listening to their private conversations.
Can you relate to this, "Hello. My name is Gail." Yes.
Cause haven't you been in a restaurant
and you hear a conversation between a couple in particular
and it's not going so well or you've been on a train
or you're even walking down the street
and you get a snippet of something?
I've actually turned around and walk behind the person,
just so I could hear the end of the story.
Are you one of those people?
Well, you love "Nancy Drew"
Yes, I do.
So that's a perfect (indistinct) thing.
I do.
I really miss it.
It was funny, Tony Dokoupil on the show, literally was like,
"Yeah, you guys should try not dating apps
and meeting in person."
I'm like, "Have you read the room the last year?
Nobody's in person."
Of course, but I do think that his point is important
because I think we will get back to that
and I try to dating app for a second.
You did?
I did.
Inspired by "Bridgerton"
I was like, "I gotta put myself back out there."
But did you go as your Drew face?
You have to be honest,
no way to start anything on deception.
I know, but Drew, I would do it.
I just don't want people to know that it's me.
I think also right now I'm a little confused.
Like, is it my girlfriends I miss?
Because for me the truth is, and I did go on a date
with a guy and he was like, "You know-"
and I was like, "No, no, no. Don't!"
Listen kids, work, girlfriends,
alone time, fifth is the guy like...
But wait, you started to say he said,
"You know, I-" What was he...
We were both talking about,
why relationships are complicated.
And I was like, "I think I'm really clear about it."
It's sort of my fifth priority and I understand...
Well, that could be a problem.
Yeah, I guess it is.
All right. Well, today we are tackling the spring cleaning
on the show and in that spirit,
we must debunk the latest viral underwear myth.
Videos on TikTok are claiming
that you must replace your underwear,
every six to nine months and I'm here to tell you,
Gail thinks its false.
Absolutely false.
Also, how many pairs of underwear are we talking about?
Well, I mean, I just think number one,
I have bras that sometimes you're putting a safety pin,
I know that's bad. I know that's bad.
But I don't understand why you'd get rid of it six
to nine months cause it's still in pretty good condition.
I think if you have multiple pairs, you're probably okay.
Well, I have multiple pairs,
don't you?
I do.
I'm not wearing the same pair of panties.
And that in that case I would suggest,
hygienically disposing of them.
But yeah, women in home asked doctors and experts
and they say, "There is no expiration date for underpants...
Yes, I believe that.
So good. It's not like a toothbrush.
I believe that.
They're underpants.
Look at the variety that you're showing.
See, those are pretty.
I feel like I should rock something more like that.
Maybe that's why we're single.
We don't wanna wear granny panties. No, no, no.
Do you wear grannies?
No, I don't.
Really?
Granny panties, no.
I'm not wearing little thongs either, but no,
I'm not wearing granny panties.
A sensible, sexy panty.
Does sensible and sexy go together, Drew?
Probably not.
I started the show in a g-string,
I'm proud to say I was really feeling myself.
Now I'm down to grannies, I gotta get back on the horse.
(upbeat music)